the girag on experience so 2019 what did
we do to Ben Askren that was you and me
bro
we had a big part of that I'm still a
fan I'm a huge fan smite quarterback I'm
a huge fan but three fights in the UFC
time go two things happen one big time
off of competing to you know competing
in one Fc
against there's not the same level of
competition I don't believe as even he
fought in Bellator I mean close and then
three you know the guy's got a fucked-up
hip he's also older other people's
people forget like you know when Ben got
to the the UFC he was the older dude he
had a lot of fights he was older they
didn't get him when he's a young this
hip things burning chicken his hip
things not a new thing all due respect
please
with all duties don't disrespect no with
all due respect due respect it's great
grappler as he is he's simply not he's
not a good striker and he's not close to
a striker that you need to be in the UFC
he just isn't if maybe I'm blind but if
you're gonna tell me that Ben Askren is
a no one so you'll argue this right
right see without being a rattler it
doesn't matter doesn't matter yeah he
didn't lose the Damon mine because of
his striking true he didn't lose he was
lucid to massive a doll that was some
crazy [ __ ] we saw that coming whatever
happened with the Robbie Lawler fight I
believe and and and whatever was really
chapter II didn't have I believe there
are guys in the UFC like that a lot of
guys like that that would have done the
same thing to him and would not have
gotten caught in that thing I mean I
don't know but I mean I been such a high
level because I won right you're right
as striking was subpar for sure good
that it doesn't matter that's why he was
there he was there because he's a
specialist I mean his grappling is off
the charts and Robbie Lawler there's no
argument whether or not Robbie Lawler
tapped he definitely didn't tap they
just thought he might have been acting
under the Wolves do think about the guys
they thought law
standing about khabib Habib's so
formidable because of his grappling and
what he couldíve didn't take any time
off like that like the the taking the
two years off that Askren took off and
being 36 he's people forget he was older
but also when you say thrown to the
wolves it's also that you were a
champion from one champions like you're
a former world champion so when he came
over the UFC ain't playing games look at
Eddie Alvarez he had a tough go look at
just engage he he use Owen - yeah like
there you want to come over here
wheelchair me again some dogs me
anything could happen it just shows you
that if you're not fighting the UFC and
I know you know Scott coach I love Scott
card if nothing else he ain't [ __ ]
here's where I disagree
Douglas Lima I think Douglas Lima might
be he might be right up there with
everybody else at 170 he might be one of
the best in the world he might be able
to knock out all of them oh yeah yeah
yeah babies Kobe might lose he might
lose but he might knock him out no
you're out of your mind man listen I
love it it is world-class he's he's
right up when I watch him fight when I
watch him fight Michael venom page when
I'm when I walked him via Donald yeah
semtex when he fought Paul Daley dude he
is he's about the guys just lista as
legit as it comes now go through kymaro
or go through Kobe's or go through
woodleigh's or Darren tills pass five
opponent that's true we're not fighting
the best day and day out
then I just you find one one guy who's
really good and then you get to up in
front of him lost to Rory in a very
close fight and beat him in the rematch
but what what I'm seeing from him is
world-class skills he and ridiculous
knockout power he may or may not be able
to beat those guys the three things you
never know but he's definitely in the
conversation yes for root for me when I
look at ability when I look at what he
can accomplish even though he's you know
he's awesome a huge 7 year he's a big
[ __ ] man he said some serious
power with a kale old chorus cough when
he ko the Michael venom page Mike he's a
monster oh thank you he could KO anyone
he's a monster yeah and I love at Lima
dos I had so much respect for him but to
me and until you're in UFC and in that
grind you know what it's true that you
can't say he's the best that's true but
you can't say he's not world class I
think that guy I'm not saying
world class but in but I can't say oh he
would be the UFC's champ or a CVS not
fine you can't say it in that division
that division is too crazy you can't say
that you need to fish monster doll could
be any 170 pounder alive on any given
night he can light up any 170 pound how
do you think you lose muscle so good
news man it's you know these guys you
got to realize humans in fighting are
never a flat board it's always this like
a little Wibbly a wobbly ankles [ __ ]
up I got a headache I'm having a hard
time wake up my girlfriend's [ __ ]
with me I'm getting over the flu they're
never exactly at the same level in every
fight so there are guys that are at a
level where you catch them when you're
up and they're down you win or they're
up and you're down and they win that's
real man
[Applause]